muy bien vamos a hablar un poco sobre el
mercado de hamburguesas tenemos las
curvas de oferta y demanda para el
precio y la cantidad de hamburguesas
vendidas por día consideramos un mercado
completamente libre sin intervenciones
ni impuestos ni nada que se le parezca a
esto entonces existe un precio
equilibrio y una cantidad de equilibrio
el precio equilibrio en este caso es de
alrededor de 3 dólares con 75 centavos
por hamburguesa mientras que la cantidad
de equilibrio parece ser de
y vamos a modificar tantito esta línea
la cantidad de equilibrio es alrededor
de tres millones y medio de hamburguesas
por día
repasando un poco lo que ya habíamos
dicho antes el área bajo la curva de
demanda y encima de la línea de precio
esto es la línea de tres dólares con 75
centavos la línea amarilla y este es el
valor bueno más bien este es el
beneficio que los consumidores están
recibiendo más allá de lo que tienen que
pagar es decir el superávit del
consumidor superávit del consumidor
ahora entre esta línea de precio de 3.75
y arriba de la curva de oferta tenemos
el superávit del productor qué significa
esto pues es cuánto ganan los
productores por cada hamburguesa
relativo a cuál es el costo de
oportunidad de producir esta hamburguesa
adicional esto de aquí es el superávit
del productor por cierto estos números
de ventas son bastante realistas de
hecho antes de hacer este vídeo
investigue y resulta que mcdonald's
según la información vende poco más de 4
millones de hamburguesas cada día en
eeuu
tampoco aclare si estas ventas son de
uno o varios vendedores para efectos del
vídeo podemos pensar que es la suma
total de ventas de todos los vendedores
de hamburguesas en algún país imaginario
claro esto implica que todas las
hamburguesas son creadas del mismo modo
y son iguales lo cual sabemos que no es
cierto pero bueno regresando al punto
supongamos que el gobierno de este país
imaginario dice vale se están vendiendo
muchísimas hamburguesas y nosotros
deberíamos obtener más ganancias de esto
para el gobierno para pagar las deudas o
lo que sea que tengan que hacer así que
deciden ponerles un impuesto a las
hamburguesas les van a poner un impuesto
y lo quieren hacer de un nuevo muy
sencillo la mayoría de los impuestos de
ventas son un porcentaje que se cobra
pero en nuestro caso vamos a suponer un
impuesto muy sencillo que consiste en
agregar un dólar del precio de la
hamburguesa
dólar
a hamburguesa
ahora que tenemos un nuevo impuesto en
juego hay que analizar su impacto en las
transacciones que se llevan a cabo en
otras palabras cómo se compara lo que va
a tener que pagar la gente contra lo que
va a obtener por su dinero
fijémonos primero en la curva de oferta
dibujada en magenta
para poder producir la primera
hamburguesa es necesario pagar el costo
de oportunidad más bajo de dos dólares
de otro modo los recursos que se van a
la elaboración de la hamburguesa podrían
ser mejor utilizados en alguna otra cosa
siguiendo con esta idea mientras más
hamburguesas quieras que fabriquen los
vendedores más les tienes que pagar
puesto que cada vez están utilizando una
mayor cantidad de recursos que quizás se
podrían usar de un modo más eficiente en
alguna otra cosa en vez de fabricar
hamburguesas así que la curva de oferta
simboliza la cantidad de dinero que
tiene que recibir un vendedor para que
le sea redituable producir un
determinado número de hamburguesas por
ejemplo si quieres que un vendedor
produzca 3 millones de hamburguesas
tienes que estar dispuesto a pagarle
tres dólares por cada una de ellas
pensamos que sucede ahora al añadir el
impuesto esto es cuánto les costaría a
los productores pero cuando añades el
impuesto los consumidores tienen que
pagar un dólar extra así que para
producir tres millones de hamburguesas
los productores tienen un costo de tres
dólares por cada hamburguesa producida
pero por culpa del impuesto los
consumidores tienen que pagar un dólar
estos tres para producir dos millones de
hamburguesas los productores tienen que
recibir poco menos de dos dólares con 50
centavos mientras que los consumidores
tendrán que pagar un dólar más llevando
el total a casi tres dólares con 50
centavos
finalmente para aquella producción en
absoluto hay que pagarles dos dólares a
los productores pero por culpa el
impuesto a los consumidores tienen que
pagar este dólar adicional un modo de
pensar en esto es que la curva de oferta
está desfasada desde el punto de vista
del consumidor ellos observando un dólar
más que los productores en el costo de
las hamburguesas así que la curva de
oferta les parece estar un poco más
elevada por culpa del impuesto para un
consumidor la curva de oferta se ve más
o menos algo así recordemos que el
impuesto es una cantidad fija de un
dólar y no es un porcentaje del precio
de venta así que en cualquier punto la
distancia entre las curvas es de un
dólar
muy bien entonces lo que está pasando
desde la perspectiva del consumidor es
que ahora tenemos un nuevo precio que
los consumidores están dispuestos a
pagar
este precio el de 3.50 ya no es viable
puesto que ya no hay modo de que los
consumidores paguen esta cantidad y que
a la vez los productores tengan este
costo de oportunidad simultáneamente
ahora tenemos un nuevo precio de
equilibrio y una cantidad de equilibrio
desde el punto de vista del consumidor
el punto donde la curva de demanda
intersec a la nueva curva de oferta
corresponde a un precio de poco más de 4
dólares por hamburguesa y a una cantidad
de redondeando un poco alrededor de 3
millones de hamburguesas al día bien qué
sucede
bueno pues antes toda esta área bajo la
curva era el superávit total por debajo
de la línea amarilla teníamos el
superávit del productor y por encima de
ella y por debajo de la curva de demanda
el superávit del consumidor ahora hemos
perdido parte del superávit hemos
perdido esta parte cita de aquí esto es
la pérdida irrecuperable de eficiencia
esto ya no es parte del total combinado
el superávit del consumidor y del
productor así que esto es una pérdida
irrecuperable noten como los impuestos
nos sacaron de una situación eficiente
donde teníamos una especie de superávit
máximo tanto para el consumidor como
para el productor y nos agregaron esta
pérdida irrecuperable
y a todo esto cuál es la ganancia el
gobierno el gobierno recibe un dólar por
cada hamburguesa vendida así que su
ganancia es el producto de la cantidad
de hamburguesas de 3 millones
multiplicada por un dólar de impuestos
por cada hamburguesa dicho de otro modo
la ganancia el gobierno es el área del
rectángulo que estoy dibujando aquí el
largo de la base el rectángulo es de 3
millones y la altura es de longitud 1 la
base es la cantidad vendida y la altura
es justamente ese dólar del impuesto así
que como la ganancia para el gobierno es
igual al área del rectángulo el impuesto
genera una ganancia diaria igual a 3
millones de hamburguesas por un dólar
dándonos el gran total de 3 millones de
dólares por día esto es en realidad muy
interesante pues quizás el gobierno
pensó que iba a obtener una mayor
ganancia porque vieron las proyecciones
originales y dijeron o se van a vender 3
millones y medio de hamburguesas por día
así que yo voy a ganar 3 millones y
medio de dólares pero no se dieron
cuenta que lo que iba a pasar es que
iban a hacer las hamburguesas más caras
y por lo tanto se iban a vender menos
que en la proyección libre de impuestos
como vimos ahora la cantidad de
equilibrio es menor de tan solo 3
millones y el impuesto eliminó parte del
superávit del consumidor y del del
productor además nadie recibe esta
porción removida ni siquiera el gobierno
es por eso que esta parte blanca se
llama pérdida irrecuperable por si fuera
poco el rectángulo anaranjado de las
ganancias del gobierno se está comiendo
un pedazo del superávit del consumidor
así que en realidad están pagando más y
recibiendo un menor beneficio los
productores también se ven afectados
puesto que la diferencia entre lo que
reciben por cada hamburguesa y su costo
de oportunidad es ahora mucho menor esto
causa que el superávit del productor
se ha reducido a esta área que estoy
sombreando justo aquí como paréntesis
noten que estas líneas son curvas así
que en realidad tienen que hacer un poco
de cálculo para poder determinar el área
de estos triángulos regresando al
superávit del consumidor este se ha
visto reducido ahora al área encerrada
por arriba de este rectángulo muy bien
como conclusión los gobiernos necesitan
de los impuestos para poder obtener
recursos ya sea el impuesto sobre la
renta o como en este caso sobre la venta
no obstante el introducir estos
impuestos provoca un estado no eficaz en
el mercado y dependiendo la forma en las
curvas de oferta y demanda provoca una
pérdida no recuperable de eficiencia así
que se pierde una parte del beneficio
adicional que se obtendría más allá del
pago pero al menos el gobierno obtiene
una ganancia ya sea esto bueno o malo